16 dezember sind die deutschen
friseursalons dicht für die friseure
bedeutet das kurzarbeitergeld fehlende
trinkgelder blanke existenzangst
manch ein friseur hat sich deswegen dazu
entschieden kunden privat zu versorgen
einer von ihnen habe ich heute mittag
treffen dürfen max b versorgt seine
kunden von zu hause aus er sagt ich
schaffe das finanziell sonst nicht die
regierung treibt mich in die illegalität
warum schneide ich heimlich habe erstmal
weil ich das so und finanziell die lok
tor nicht überstehen
ja und zweitens denke jeder mensch
braucht ein haarschnitt und man fühlt
sich halten wolle auch wenn man zu hause
im lockdown sitzt trotzdem fühlt man
sich besser mit nach schnitt wenn man
frisch rasiert ist oder frisch gefärbte
also deswegen weil die leute auch was
gutes theater trotzdem ein jahr zwei
alba freundeskreis und die machen eine
privat weiter also das geht sonst nicht
anders schaffen die nicht und das müssen
wir wie gesagt irgendwie muss würdigen
wusste die miete weiterhin gezahlt
werden ja und lauda weiter lieben können
ja und werden nun nicht arbeitet und
keine hilfe kriegs und nicht
funktioniert ist alles nicht richtig
seit 22 jahren friseur natürlich in der
zeit hat mal einer sehr großen kunden
sterben und teilweise von dating auf dem
logport habe ich echt viele menschen die
zu mir gekommen sind jedoch teilweise
auch selber in ihren profilen schreiben
ich suche dringend friseur zu mir kommen
auch polizisten und alles war jetzt er
seiner unterlassen tiere geworden hat
als jetzt angesprochen so quasi und wo
finde ich die deutlich gegen den alten
und propaganda über freunde über
facebook sozialen medien also wir hoffen
dass wir am 14 oder am 17 loslegen
können aber man weiß es ja nicht
natürlich müssten wir weil
diese prämien selbst beschaffen die
laden vielleicht nicht mehr haben kann
ja weil es noch länger dauert das hoffen
wir mal dass wir es bald wieder los
linke es geht einfach nicht mehr ist es
für uns friseure ist das macht uns
kaputt er nicht gewirkt
im schlimmsten fall haben die friseure
mit der einleitung eines strafverfahrens
wegen der schwarzarbeit dass
unterbliebene ab führens von
arbeitnehmer- beträgen oder eben auch
der veruntreuung von geldern nicht
abhelfen steuern zu rechnen in jedem
fall droht ihnen die einleitung eines
bußgeldverfahrens wegen des verstoßes
gegen die korona schutzverordnung wie
sieht es denn aus sagen wir mal ein
freund von mir ist friseur kommt jetzt
zu mir nach hause
ich lade ihn dafür zum essen ein und
vielleicht ja weil ich weiß und sie sind
gerade finanziell nicht gut geht gebe
ich ihm auch noch ein schein ist das
auch verboten
ja das ist leider auch verboten das
tätigkeitsverbot gilt derzeit umfassend
es ist in allen bundesländern verboten
auch privat zu hause von einem friseur
auch wenns befreundet ist die haare
schneiden zu lassen
der friseure hat mit einem bußgeld zu
rechnen von 1000 euro aber auch ich als
bundessieger ein fußgänger im bereich
von 50 bis 250 euro drohen wegen
verletzung der masken pflicht gegen das
nicht einhalten das mindestabstand von
anderthalb
metern in dem handwerk
vielen dank das war sehr aufschlussreich
also sowohl den illegalen friseurin als
auch mir selbst als kunden würden
strafen drohen vielen dank dass sie sich
die zeit genommen haben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren